MATTHEW GAUNT: Hi, Pete.
PETE LEPAGE: Hi, Matt.
MATTHEW GAUNT: So what's this?
PETE LEPAGE: The device wall.
MATTHEW GAUNT: What's
the device wall?
PETE LEPAGE: It's
a wall of devices.
MATTHEW GAUNT: So
seriously, though,
like what's the point
of the device wall?
PETE LEPAGE: So the
point of the device wall
is to give web
developers an opportunity
to see what their website
looks like across all different
devices, whether it's brand
new device or something that's
been around for a long time,
to be able to see your site
and how it works is
kind of important.
MATTHEW GAUNT: And
obviously we've got Android.
We've got some iPhone.
We got Microsoft
Services, Chromebox,
which obviously that means you
start getting different browser
support and all the
other kind of things
like that, which is always fun.
So why is this useful?
PETE LEPAGE: Well, so we
found a couple of bugs.
And probably my favorite bug is
one we found on one of our own
sites on google.com/chrome.
If you take a look at the
site-- let me grab this.
So one of the most
important things
you can do when building
a responsive site
is make sure that it remains
within the view port.
So it looks like
it's in the view port
and if you were
using an emulator
or something like that, you'd
be like, oh, hey, yeah, look,
everything's in the view port.
Look at all that text,
it fits perfectly.
No, it doesn't.
By moving the browser
around and actually
playing with it
on a real device,
you can find bugs that
you'd not find otherwise.
We came across
one site on a site
Paul Kinlan built,
the Air Horner app,
which if you're looking
for something fun--
the Air Horner app.
MATTHEW GAUNT: Don't
advertise his app.
It's a terrible, terrible app.
No.
Bad Pete.
But the other side of this
as well is we hooked it up.
So it's looking for
OpenWare platform features,
like HBS, Service Worker,
Theme Color, which
is super, simple for
people to add in,
and it gets a really nice
branding to the site.
We've also got PageSpeed
Insights and WebPagetest,
and that basically looks
at performance issues
that you might have
with your site,
and it gives you a
nice score, which
is really simple like for
helping people figure out,
OK, how is my site
roughly doing,
which is really, really nice.
Anything else?
Anyone can use this?
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely
anybody can use this.
There we go.
Anybody can use it.
You can go to our
GitHub repository.
It's up on GitHub
at GoogleChrome/Min
iMobileDeviceLab.
Give it a try.
It's a ton of fun, easy to use.
MATTHEW GAUNT: Nailed it.
PETE LEPAGE: Thanks, Matt.
That was fun.
MATTHEW GAUNT: Bye, Pete.
PETE LEPAGE: Bye, Matt.
[MUSIC PLAYING]